hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slomo guys we've done some relatively
dangerous subjects in the past haven't
we such as explosion
it honestly looks like that was fired
from a fat man yeah and gun
both very good videos they are good
videos but there is something that
worries me way more than both of those
and it's extremely powerful magnets such
as these bad boys this is four very
attractive neodymium magnets with these
magnets you can very briefly lose
concentration and forget that these
inanimate objects can slam together or
slam into something and powder your hand
with a gun at least you've got sort of
control of the moment that happens you
know you're in control of the weapon
with explosions you can hide again
you're in control with these they're
just constantly 24 7 trying to like and
like attract the nearest metal thing in
the room it's a good point actually I've
got my phone
and wallet right here
with credit cards in it so
that's better okay good yeah I've
removed my watch my belt my Prince
Albert and my wallet obviously because I
don't want to get my hand or anything
else powdered and crushed shall we whip
out a very fast Phantom and film them
smashed together insane frame rates
let's do that
there oh
okay here we go coming in with magnet
do you think that's a long enough
distance away that they're not going to
attract each other right now yeah I
think so but I mean just for safety we
won't have anything between them no
doing a little polarity check here yep
that's attractive but I started feeling
it here really oh yeah so the dot on the
back of the magnet means away from the
other magnet
okay then I'm putting this back
I'm at 187 500 frames a second that's
the number you've chosen well that's
just the max speed at the resolution
I've chosen just to try and get a little
bit more I see detail in the crack okay
I'm putting the magnet in
Magna is in
whoa wow
wow I saw the Sparks from here that was
so cool
it's made like a just a jumbled mangle
of magnet
a jumbled mango yeah it just like folded
in on itself like space and time it
looks like the icon for like a metal
resource that you'd collect in a video
game doesn't it like this isn't all that
you dig up off a planet yeah now there
was some small tiny pieces that I heard
flying around I got sent they got sent
but because the pieces that are larger
are so magnetic they I imagine they went
Bang
into each other yeah wow that's
incredible that's a work of art quite
excited to see this yeah me too because
I blinked and I missed it it was so
quick yeah these everything we filmed
with this camera the ultimate like blink
and you'll miss it subject see so it's
already left your plank yeah it's out of
my hands now look how evenly they're
traveling I think it's like I said where
the friction won't matter because
they're look it's honestly like it's
like they're gonna meet directly in the
middle do you know what they look like
um if it was a completely black
background they would look like Borg
cubes
just like crashing into each other a
bunch of balls yeah
yeah this is really building the tension
I can't wait to see what's gonna happen
yeah I wonder if they're like what the
acceleration is like the closer they get
to each other you know so obviously I
first started seeing it I could see the
move I mean it's gonna be exponential
isn't it wow all right I'm gonna slow
down to actual slow-mo speed now oh this
is gonna be so satisfying
[Music]
oh God look at them break apart like
that
they've just imploded yeah and stuff is
flying away so is that all going to turn
back around oh this is so cool I can't I
really want I hope okay let's speed up
slightly
is anything going to get brought back
it's all like curving in on itself
wow it's like uh
that is wicked it's all just come
together and made this well it's left
the frame jumped up yeah we thought that
might happen didn't we yeah
oh look at it like it looks like it is
in space you know how left right up see
you later but couldn't have been more
perfect at the time of impact I think
that the rear of the magnet hit like a
nanosecond before the front did so
before the crack oh yeah you see what I
mean like there's like a millimeters
explode at the back yeah like so the
biggest impact was probably on the other
side so where do the Sparks come from
the Sparks come from like the pointing I
think yeah so like a really sharp Point
grinding on other stuff is What spark do
it again wide over the island okay get
some of that leap maybe it's come in and
then the Smashing attractiveness has
caused it to explode rather and then
that's caused the damage to the surface
here and little chipping chipages you
see that little bits everywhere it's
rare that we have um chipping chipages
in a video yeah so this is exciting you
know what that footage reminded me of go
on uh when we saw each other after the
pandemic
because we were
really just running towards each other
oh yeah we didn't explode in the street
we didn't explode though yeah
there were Sparks there
I scooped the magnet and attempted to
scoop it into a box yeah and there's
like metal
bits underneath this table and it's just
it fell down and just attached itself to
the table
I mean and that is where the all spark
remains
this box we've got a better label it or
Berry or something and bury it just bury
it in the ground someone walks past with
some like metal toed shoes
like false knee
okay we have a nice tight but it jumped
pretty high at frame so we switched to
the t4040 we're at 10 000 frames a
second a little bit wider yeah I've also
removed this back piece of wood to
hopefully get a nice sort of sexy
cleaner image of the magnets smashing
together I've messed up my watch with
those magnets so many times the Jewelers
are like magnets again
and like yeah I'm like a regular
customer there
oh yeah now now they're the correct
polarity do you see that I saw it I
don't think the camera did but the
magnet on the other side of the wood
just went flip 360. yeah okay
so I'm gonna move this back into the box
that was so far away as well you ready
yeah I'm ready I've put a bit of
Headroom on it just in case it takes a
nice leap okay
flip
oh something hit your like I think it's
a piece of magnet on your like metal
trolley over there
[Applause]
so scary every single time every time
it's so harmless right now
oh
look at the way it all twist
[Music]
weird it's like some sort of amorph like
a kind of like a a metal that's been
given life oh big spark on the corner
there I saw that one with my eye I think
oh look at all this stuff that's flown
out on the bottom left get a little
sucked back in there that's very rare
that in an explosion like this because
it's kind of an explosion right yeah you
see pieces spinning and then stop
spinning and spin the other way yeah
because it's like usually like you've
set something on emotion that's it but
this is like just spinning all different
directions and it's so cool this little
part on the on the bottom left look it
flew off
slammed into the wood didn't spin
and then just sort of wibbles back
towards them oh yeah it goes like it
looks like a fish it's being pulled but
it's not the right shape anymore so it's
like swinging back and forth and this is
all moving so it's just wobbly you just
about just kept it in frame there really
yeah landed out of focus but I can't ask
for everything can you no lovely looking
footage excellent remnants very artistic
I love the way that looks I'd actually
have that as a fancy paperweight if it
wouldn't
suck all my paper clips into it your
paper clips do you you own paper clips I
don't actually have any paper clips
I don't think I have a metal pen either
plastic pen yeah you could you could
sort of if you wanted to avoid your
paper clips falling into it you could
surround it in resin like in a little
resin oh yeah they have to be out to
here probably yeah like a giant movie
box just in case there's any other
magnets nearby make sure you don't mess
with these don't try that at home
they're extremely dangerous I'm very
happy this video is over are you I can't
wait to put it down excellent thank you
very much for watching we'll see you
next time